le mostré de mi casa
serpiente
para que nos dejen respirar
gracias por ser tan valiente
y todos morimos diferente
no nos vana
ayer te oí decirlo
tiempo sanará
y el otro
me dijo
que nada pasa
no cruzo yo mismo
el mar de mi dolor
el mar de mis abismo
de pérdida de visión
[Música]
y si supieras qué
lloro
de lluvia pongo el bosque
[Música]
te enterramos el tesoro hoy cruzamos
abandono
digamos
ayer te oí decirlo
ganarás
pero atrás
pasa
si no cruzo yo mismo
el mar de mi dolor
el mar de misa mismo
me ves
a mí
pero otra vez me dijo
pasará
si no soy yo mismo
y yo no
televisa mismo
sexy
el tiempo sanará
el tiempo
el mar de mi sadismo
el mal de mis abismo
de mí
mi decepción
[Música]
no mirar atrás
no mirara hasta ahora
[Música]
en el desierto
esto
de ese recuerdo atrás
no miedo
lento
puedes ver dolor
al mal de la tierra
brillo de la luz
mira
[Aplausos]
con la cicatriz
y cantar
[Música]
sí
y
mirar atrás no mirar atrás
[Música]
mientras
en el desierto y suelo
[Música]
yo suelo
él aspira
la dra
tanto
este
ellas
[Música]
miedo árbol de la tierra
brillo
llegar hasta aquí
[Música]
seguro
de tu carrera
[Música]
no
sólo eran pesados
i
de manera
[Música]
y
y soy músico soy compositor aquí estaba
tocando dos canciones mías en compañía
de daniel claves guitarrista en mi banda
llevo diez doce años con este proyecto
funcionando como solista de rock en
colombia haciendo canciones haciendo
conciertos haciendo discos
y bueno además de ser músico tengo otra
otra otra faceta de mi vida ser
psicoterapeuta y trabajar en terapia con
gente
y parte algo muy clave para mí en mi
vida y que ha nutrido mucho tanto mi
trabajo como psicoterapeuta como mi
música y sobre todo las letras
es haber estado andando como un camino
interior con un camino espiritual por
así decirlo de búsqueda de búsqueda
interna de búsqueda como de cómo de
darle sentido a la vida y algo que es
muy relevante en el caso de estas dos
canciones que es un tema que de fondo o
que ambas tienen es como de darle
sentido al dolor
todos todos traemos ya como bagaje de
vida heridas eso es inevitable
la búsqueda es
es como de darle es qué hacer con eso
qué hacer con esas heridas o qué hacer
con el dolor es una búsqueda como de
reivindicar como esa sombra que es como
todas esas cosas que normalmente los
humanos no queremos experimentar no
queremos como como sentir
pero que un poco lo que dicen las
canciones es que precisamente nos vamos
haciendo más libres de esas ataduras
dolorosas a medida a medida que vamos
siendo más y más capaces no de evitarlas
no de combatirlas sino todo lo contrario
como de como de darles la bienvenida a
nuestra vida y andar con ellas andar con
ellas como como teniendo una relación
con esa parte
otra parte digamos dolorosa o herida
vuelvo y digo que sea una relación donde
donde hay como cierta aman amabilidad
con esa parte dura donde no tenemos como
que ocultar ni ocultarnos por por eso y
es como en ese proceso de esa nueva
relación como des alquimia con esa
sombra
que va apareciendo un poco más la
capacidad de vivir sin estar siendo como
tan definidos tan limitados por esos
pasados difíciles entonces las dos
canciones creo que son una invitación
como a eso a como a mirar de frente todo
lo que no trae por dentro precisamente
para integrar lo para
y poderse parar sin estar en luchas sin
estar en combate con distintas partes de
uno mismo
y bueno esa es como la propuesta vital
de las letras de las canciones y es algo
que para mí es muy importante y que sigo
como recorriendo y explorando y
aprendiendo como en la vida entonces
esas dos canciones fueron el tiempo no
sana se llama así precisamente porque
dice que lo que salga no es el tiempo
solito sino sino en nuestra mirada hacia
adentro como estaba hablando critica el
tiempo nos sana y no mirar atrás y las
dos canciones están en un disco niño del
2017 que se llama todo empieza ahora que
también recalca todo este mensaje de la
vida de mirar la vida aquí y ahora en el
presente
y caminar desde cada presente en la vida